[MUSIC PLAYING]
ABBY: I'm thrilled
to be here today
with Kelly Hoey, the author
of "Build Your Dream Network."
Kelly is a connector
and has been
on the "Forbes" one of five
women changing the world in VC
and entrepreneurship.
She's appeared on
CNBC's "Power Pitch,"
keeps a column on inc.com, and
tweets frequently at @jkhoey.
In addition to her portfolio
of angel investments,
she's an LP in two
funds and an adviser
to the New Zealand Trade
and Enterprise Commission.
On top of these
professional pursuits,
Kelly is a chief tech
ambassador for the YWCA
up at NYC [INAUDIBLE]
Girls' Club.
Please join me in
welcoming Kelly.
[APPLAUSE]
We're really excited
to have you here.
KELLY HOEY: I'm excited
to be here with you.
ABBY: Great.
So the word
networking sends a lot
of chills down people's
spines, including my own.
And I might even
dare to say there's
other people in the room that
would prefer to treat the word
networking like an
elephant in the room,
and maybe keep it
in closed corners.
But without
networking, your career
would have never gotten
to where you are today.
And you talk about
this a bit in the book.
But would you mind
sharing with us
how this idea of networking and
how it's creatively developed
brought you from 2002
to where you are today?
KELLY HOEY: Yeah, so my
background is I'm an attorney.
I practiced law in Canada
and in New York City,
made a career change,
decided I wanted
to make a career change
in 2002 and realized
I didn't have the
network to do it,
even though I was
looking for a career
within the same industry.
And everything since then has
come about because of networks,
and relationships, and purposely
building strong connections.
So as Abby mentioned,
the word networking
put chills in their spine.
It puts a chill in my spine.
I confess in the book--
I am a reluctant networker.
I was also very reluctant
at public speaking,
so the universe does really have
a way of coming back at you.
When you think of networking
as working a room,
if you all think about--
say the word networking,
you're probably
imagining a cocktail party.
There's a name tag that
you have to pin somewhere.
You're probably balancing
some sort of a drink,
trying to talk to someone.
Someone introduces you.
You're pulling off some
satay off a little stick--
the horrors, right?
Like having to talk about
the weather or something--
you're just like, ugh.
That is not networking to me.
That's a networking tactic.
But networking, to me, when
you think of it as an activity
is every single
human interaction.
So when you think about
your own lives, for me,
networking was your
decision to be here today.
Your networking is your
email signature line.
It's the headshot you all
have on fabulous name tags
or on social media.
It is-- I don't know,
maybe, did someone
leave a voicemail message
for someone else today?
Did you hand out
a business card?
Did you, I don't know,
leave an out-of-office
responder that says you
weren't going to be around?
To me, every time we
interact with someone else,
that is networking.
And those micro-actions,
in my mind,
are what are more
effective in moving
our careers, and our ambitions,
and our relationships
forward than relying on
balancing a cocktail plate,
and handing out a
business card, and having
something smart to say
at a cocktail party.
So if networking
is an activity, I
want you to think about it
as every human interaction,
and how can you do those better?
Networking is a mindset.
I want you to
think about it as--
this is really hard
for a lot of people--
how can you be a
decent human being,
because I think
that's all we're ever
looking for is, how can we
have someone who listens to us
and is considerate?
And then networking is--
well, where do you start
when someone says something
foolish to you like, do more
networking, because we've all
heard that one.
That's great.
How do I start doing that--
is where are you headed?
Where are you going?
What are you trying
to achieve right now
with the help of other people?
And then who are the
people who can help you?
Are they people already
in your network?
Are they groups or
organizations that you may
be thinking you need to join?
Now, how can you communicate
with them better?
Because part of networking
is our preference
on how we communicate
and engage.
And the other is the person
you want to interact with.
So I mentioned that
I said voicemail as--
I think it's an
act of networking.
My voicemail message,
if anyone calls me,
says, please don't leave
me a voicemail message.
I don't listen to them.
The number of people who still
leave me voicemail messages
is comical.
And I can tell you what I do
with every single one of them--
Delete.
I've stated my preference.
Text me, or email
me, or tweet me.
Do not leave me a voicemail--
I don't listen to these.
ABBY: There you are with
the Twitter handle again.
[LAUGHTER]
So this is a pretty
significant re-brand
to the idea of
networking, and especially
what we hear in business
communities, or in an MBA
session, or anything like that.
KELLY HOEY: Well, I want
to say we get so enamored--
I want to say I
think we've become
so enamored with technology
and ways things can do things
faster.
We don't have to pull
out a paper map anymore.
Thankfully, Google can
get us our directions.
We can click, and
swipe, and tap.
But we need to remember-- behind
all of this is human beings.
And we have messy,
complicated, unusual lives.
And on any given day, we can
be in a good mood or a bad mood
or have some trigger
that sets us off.
And your reaction
to something might
be different than my
reaction to something.
And so I think if nothing
else from this book, if people
put people back in the
center of your networking
and think, how can I
be someone other people
want to network
with, how can I be
the person I want
to network with,
and just add that
little consideration
into your daily activities.
I think it will make all
the world of difference.
ABBY: So digging into that a
little bit, one of the themes
that Kelly talks about in her
book is the "Give, Give, Get"
theory.
And while it might seem a
little bit self-explanatory,
we'd love to hear
your thoughts on it
and how you came
to it, when we're
thinking about putting
people back in networking,
people back in
relationship building.
KELLY HOEY: Well, it's great
to be talking about it here
at Google and in the heart of
Silicon Valley, where there has
often been, and it has been
built on this "Give, Give, Get"
mentality.
But that is sort of one of
those old rules of networking.
I think there's an element
of resurrecting Miss Manners
or Craig Claiborne and wrapping
them around our networking
activities again.
And the idea is, have you been
a good person in the community
within which you are operating?
Have you been that
colleague who has
been helpful to other people?
Kathryn Finney, who is--
the book is very
case-study driven.
Kathryn Finney, one of
the interviewees-- and she
has the BIG accelerator
out of Atlanta.
And she says if you can't
call upon a network,
you probably have a low
return on generosity.
And then you need to look at
what your own interactions are.
I think that idea of the
"Give, Give, Get," though,
is hard for some people,
because there's often
a networking imbalance.
You're looking to
network with someone
who is higher up a corporate
ladder or someone who
apparently has more resources,
connections than you do.
And that's where I come back to
what I said before about being
a decent human being.
Are you considerate of
somebody else's time when
you're asking them for advice?
Do you follow up
and let them know
what you did with that advice?
Have you done enough
research so that if you're
taking someone's time to
ask them the question,
you're asking them
the right question?
If they've already
written it on a blog,
if they've shared it
on a YouTube video,
if they have posted
it endlessly,
why would you ask
a question that you
could find out the answer
to in a Google search?
You could do that work,
read it all, take it all in,
and then ask them
a better question.
In my mind, that is
networking generosity.
And that is an essential "give,"
I think, in this day and age,
before you ask for time, because
we have two resources in life,
really--
time and reputation.
One, you can maybe earn
back-- your reputation.
You can never get
back your own time,
and you can never give
back anybody else's time.
So really, that essential
"give" in networking,
for me, is doing your homework
before you make that ask.
ABBY: To maximize
that time and maximize
the giving of the other person,
instead of wasting their time.
KELLY HOEY: Right, and
realize that that level
of consideration is enough of
a "give," because like I said,
people are like, oh my god.
If I ask someone
for an introduction,
what am I going to give them?
You don't need to give
them an equal introduction.
You may never have
that opportunity,
and they may never want it.
But you can give
them consideration.
You can give them that kindness.
You can give them
that thoughtfulness.
And that-- it sounds like
a really low base level,
but the number of people
who sort of, like,
this is all we need--
one of the other people
interviewed in the book
is Alison Levine.
Alison is-- and how many friends
do you get to say in life
are an adventurer?
She's a bestselling author,
but she's also an adventurer.
She has led the first all-US
women's team up Everest,
amongst other accomplishments
and mountains,
literally, that she has climbed.
And when I asked her about
networking generosity
and what was the "give"--
because, of course,
she's accomplished so much,
people ask her for so much.
And she just said,
you know what?
Just be considerate.
Be considerate about the
time that you're asking for.
Be considerate about
what you're asking for.
Don't ask me if I've
climbed Everest.
A Google search
will reveal that.
And she was so
adamant on this, I
had to call her and
say, Ali, I need
to edit your
answers for my book,
because if I kept
her original answers,
the book would come in
a brown paper wrapper
with a parental warning on it--
a lot of all caps, a lot
of imaginative words.
And it sounds crazy, but just
that little consideration
makes all the difference.
ABBY: So Alison was actually
at Google last week.
And now you're making me--
I'm going to watch
her talk, when
it was recorded, because
she sounds fantastic, yeah.
KELLY HOEY:
[INAUDIBLE] seriously,
if you missed her in
person, watch her talk.
Alison Levine is extraordinary.
ABBY: OK, [INAUDIBLE]?
Fantastic.
So on that idea of
frequent networking
asks that we might
get or questions
that might come in
often, especially
for someone like you who
identifies as a connector, one
of the ideas I wanted
to run through by Kelly
was to self-assess and look at
some of the networking emails
I've sent or I've received
with leading questions.
And I want to read
these out, because I
think these are often networking
crutches that we land on.
I want to pick your
brain about something.
KELLY HOEY: Talk to the
hand on that one, seriously.
Don't send that email.
ABBY: And we'll break some
of these down afterwards.
But if you think of
anyone for this--
KELLY HOEY: Uh-uh, nope.
ABBY: Do you have any
opportunities in mind
for me to grow?
You mean you don't
know everything
about my personal and
professional development?
KELLY HOEY: No, no.
ABBY: Do you know anyone that
might want to cover this story
or give me some publicity?
KELLY HOEY: The number
of that last one--
the number of times I get that
from emerging tech companies
who've hired PR firms, and
that's what they email me--
oh, for the love of god.
ABBY: So as someone
who's relatively
young in their career, and when
I'm thinking about networking
vertically, and I'm talking
to folks that I know
I want to make most
value of their time,
but I also don't
want to overstep.
I don't want to come
off as asking too much.
So sometimes it can feel
more comfortable to go back
to these general statements.
KELLY HOEY: But those
questions are asking too much.
ABBY: Why is that?
KELLY HOEY: Think
about an email you
get from a friend that
says, I'm looking for a job.
How does that feel
when you get that?
You're like, I don't
know where to start.
So what do you have
to start by doing?
You have to start by
asking a lot of questions
and racking your brain.
Well, do you want
a job at Google,
or were you looking
for a job at Wal-Mart?
I don't know.
What are you looking for?
And when you ask big,
general questions,
you're making your network
do the work for you,
rather than giving
them that target.
Think about it like darts.
You've got a target
that you're going for.
Tell them what your bullseye
is, because then we have
a radius of ways to help you.
So if you said, hey, I'm
looking for a job at X,
and you're like, I
don't know anyone at X,
but I know someone at Y--
I don't know anyone at NBC,
but I know someone at ABC.
Would you want to talk to them--
we have something to aim at.
But if you said, I'm just
looking for a new job,
I don't know what to shoot for.
And now you've put
the work on me,
and that is too heavy of an ask.
I think our networks have been
extraordinarily strained, when
I think of it from, probably,
about 2009, when you think
the economic collapse, and
Lehman Brothers, all of that
stuff going on, and people
strained and looking
for opportunities.
I think our networks
are strained
because our nature
of work has changed.
So many of us do freelance.
Or we're looking to get
opportunities and experiences
within one company, and then
we're moving to another.
So we're constantly
moving in and out
of opportunities and networks.
So you're better off, and
you're helping your network,
you're helping
yourself, and you're
helping you get a better
answer if you're specific.
And people are afraid
of going specific.
And maybe they're afraid
of doing the work.
But a lot of people say to me,
but if I do all that research
and ask the question, I
have to do a lot of work.
And I'm like, yeah,
that's the point.
That's why it's "net-work,"
so that "work" word in it.
But it's also-- if you
get off on just sending
50 emails saying, hey,
I'm looking for a job,
can you help me, that's time.
Sitting around waiting
for an answer is time.
Why not do the research?
Find a smaller group of
people within your network
who can provide you
with the right answer
or closer to the right answer.
Spend your networking time on
that front end, doing that--
ask a better question.
You don't need 50 people
emailing you back.
You need one or two
to email you back
with the right opportunity.
ABBY: I think-- so
yes to all of that,
and to give a plug to your book
"Build Your Dream Network," one
of the things that I
loved about this book
is that you talked about how to
figure out what you're asking
in the networking, anyways.
You should have a goal in mind.
KELLY HOEY: Right.
ABBY: And sometimes we know
that this ambiguous networking
concept is important,
but we don't know
why we need to be doing it.
And that brings to random
acts of networking.
KELLY HOEY: Right, well, when
we think of what you started,
like the bad name
on networking--
if I don't know why I'm
in a networking room,
I'm equally sweaty palms
and anxious as anyone else.
I'm like, why am I here?
What am I going to talk about?
But if I know why I'm there, if
I've made a conscious decision
to be there, it's a heck of
a lot easier to figure out,
all right, what are we
going to talk about?
What's an introductory
question that I
would want to say to someone?
Or if my networking
is I just need
to discover what this group
or organization or association
is all about, I'm happy to
go and sit quietly and assess
the landscape to
understand, right,
do I want to spend more
time here in the future?
ABBY: But that all should
align back to the goals
that you have set before even
walking into the room, correct?
KELLY HOEY: Right, because
yeah, otherwise you
run around like a chicken
with your head cut off.
And listen, our time is--
we have not been
able to hack time.
There's still only 24 hours--
ABBY: Anybody working on that?
KELLY HOEY: I don't know.
Maybe someone's
working on it here.
We could just reverse things
every once in a while--
met George Takei at
[INAUDIBLE] a few years ago.
And I said to him, still
mad with "Star Trek"
that we don't have that "Beam
me up, Scotty" technology.
That would be good too.
So we don't have
more time in the day.
And for many of us,
well, work is important.
There's other things
that are important.
And your networking is also
important for your community
service.
It may be important for
other things in your life.
And frankly, just having time
to be with other people that
are close to you--
make a priority for that.
So I'm very much about
efficiency, you know?
Maybe it's women-- multitasking,
how can you pack more
into things we're
already doing, rather
to add more things on
when our time is limited.
ABBY: Great, thank you.
I would say for folks that are
interested more in about goal
setting and thinking about
those meta levels of career
development, I would
highly recommend
checking out the book.
The chapters on goal
setting helped me a lot,
personally, with thinking
about time at Google.
And it made some of those
networking questions
a little bit clearer and
some of the steps easier
too-- so just a plug.
KELLY HOEY: [INAUDIBLE]
it was funny.
One of the early
readers of my book
sort of called me
up and said, I've
got some bad news
about your book.
And I said, what's the bad news?
And she's like, it's
not about networking.
And I'm like, yeah,
I had that suspicion.
And I think it is a
bigger look at what
is it that you want to achieve?
And you achieve things with
the help of other people.
Now, how can you form
better relationships,
and how can you
focus what you're
doing so you can achieve it?
So the case studies
in the book range
from working up the
corporate ladder
to crowdfunding to getting
on a national board
to, I want to say, landing
a job right out of college--
how Tina Roth Eisenberg
created CreativeMornings,
a global network for
the creative community.
So it's more than just how you
balance a drink and work room.
And it has gotten a few people
thinking about, all right,
what do I want to
achieve with my career?
What do I want to
do after I retire?
I have a friend's mom inspired
to start her own business
after she retires as a
schoolteacher in June,
because she read the book.
ABBY: That's pretty cool.
It's going to be exciting to
see where this book brings
people over the years as well.
I'm sure you're going to
be getting some fun emails
or tweets tracking that down.
KELLY HOEY: And those are
the things that matter to me.
When I get those, to
think that something
has unlocked something
for someone else,
and now they can pursue a
path to their own success--
something very
gratifying in that.
ABBY: So I want to
jump back to something
you were talking about earlier,
around us owning our reputation
and owning our time.
And one thing that really
stood out to me in the book
was, you kept bringing
back this idea of,
who knows what you know?
Or the way I would rephrase
it is, what are you known for?
And I think my question
for you, right off the bat,
would be, how do you know
who knows what you know?
[LAUGHTER]
If everyone keeps up with that--
KELLY HOEY: Well, because
part of the way I see that is,
I think about how the job
market and opportunities have
evolved from who you know--
you know, those
insider networks--
to maybe what you know,
because it was a world driven
by help wanted, and
recruiters, and classified ads,
to now a world where I put
it as, it's not who you know
or what you know, but
who knows what you know.
And I mention this in the book.
I remember when I
was researching,
and I pulled up something.
And it popped up--
and it was in LinkedIn.
It popped up an
opportunity at Google.
So I went and clicked on it.
And then it said, by the way,
who do you know at Google?
Why don't you contact them?
And I'm like, yeah, what
is the information you're
sharing with your
network, in terms
of what your interests
are, what maybe
you want to do next, what
in your life and your career
that you want more of, because
the signals you send out
may be the stuff
that starts coming
to you as the opportunities
that you're really seeking.
So go and look at
your own profiles.
Go and look at the information
that you're sharing,
whether it's in person,
online or offline,
with your community, because
you may be sending out
the wrong signals in terms of
what you want to be found for.
I know on my profile,
you don't see anything
about being a lawyer.
It is so buried and so
minimal with search words
and everything
else, because lord
knows I don't want to
be contacted on that.
ABBY: So when we're thinking
about our email signatures,
or our Twitter
headlines, or even
our bios on our internal
job-search boards,
do you think that those
should all be the same,
and we should know what
people are identifying us as?
KELLY HOEY: Right, make sure
it's powerfully moving forward
your ambition.
If you're posting things
online, what are the stories
that you're sharing?
If you're sharing
rich content that
is dealing with your profession
or your career interests,
are you sharing in a way that
people are identifying it
with something that you
either are an expert in,
or you want to move into, or
something that you care about?
We have that
ability and mobility
to move between things.
My own personal story
was, in 2011, 2012,
I co-founded a
startup accelerator.
It was not my idea, though I
was one of the co-founders.
The original idea came
from my two co-founders,
and they realized in launching
this nutty, crazy idea
that they needed somebody
else to help them.
And they kept talking
to people and describing
the skill set,
and the abilities,
and the background
they were looking
in this third co-founder,
nameless third co-founder.
And my name kept coming up.
Everyone kept saying,
you know what?
You need to talk to Kelly-- you
know who you should talk to?
You should talk to Kelly.
So what do you want
to be known for?
Network that experience.
Network that ambition.
Network that skill set.
Let people know what
you're interested in,
because they may be like, oh,
I know who you're looking for.
You're looking for
someone like Kelly,
or you're looking for
someone like Abby.
Let me-- you should
talk to them,
sounds like a great opportunity.
And that's how
everything in my life
has happened,
really, since 2009.
ABBY: For folks that are
listening in right now
and saying that sounds great,
I need to update my headline,
or, my goodness,
I don't know what
people know me for right now,
do you have any take actions--
and I won't say a
quick win, but areas
that people could
take away today
to start to change
their headline,
change what they're known for?
KELLY HOEY: Right, well,
take an audit of every place
where you're interacting
with other people and say,
is there this consistency?
Is this networking me forward
in the way I want to be found?
And then stop and think.
And say, all right, how is my
network interacting with me?
What are they asking me for?
How are they engaging with me?
Now, how much of
that is my network?
Do I have the
right mix of people
in it, in terms of
relationships and diversity?
Or how is my terms of
engagement with it,
that I've enabled them to keep
calling me back and asking
for these things?
It's a little of both.
So go and do that audit, and
sort of assess and say, oops.
What needs to shift and change?
ABBY: Great, action item for me.
[LAUGHTER]
KELLY HOEY: I do it myself.
I was saying it is one
of those things that's
kind of funny-- write
a book on networking,
and you have to eat
your own dog food.
And I have to follow the
advice between the two covers.
So I'm not just sitting up here,
flippantly tossing out, oh, you
should do this.
It's like, I have
to do it myself.
[LAUGHTER]
And I do catch myself
every once in a while.
[LAUGHTER]
ABBY: So you
actually just started
to touch on something that
I'm excited you brought up
around diversity of networks and
where we find these groupings.
And we actually had a great
speaker at Google last year,
Tara Winston.
I'm not sure if other
folks were able to tune in.
She's from Interact
Consulting and was
giving a skills-building
session at Google last year.
And she had a quote that
stood out to me that I'd
love to hear your thoughts on.
She warned us against
putting your entire network
in the same food chain.
And I'll leave it
at that, and I'd
love to hear what
you think about that.
Break it down.
KELLY HOEY: Well, that was
the position I was in in 2002.
I had a network that
was very narrow and very
deep within the legal
industry, but very particular
within the legal industry.
It was New York
City and Toronto.
It was bankers, investment
bankers, Wall Street,
I want to say trustees.
It was within a very
narrow area of practice.
And even though,
then, my next career
move I saw within
the legal industry,
I had nowhere to go unless I
wanted to go a general counsel
or move to another firm
and do the same thing.
And so that was a big
wake-up call for me.
So I'm doing this
because there's basically
two types of networks.
Some of them are
associated with gender.
And some of it, I
want to say, like
I describe my own legal
career-- some of us,
because of our industry
and our profession,
we do this with our network.
It becomes very expertise
and very narrow.
So there's a
narrow, deep network
that's often associated with
women, the types of networks
they have.
As I described it, I guess I
had the double whammy on that.
I also had it because
I was a lawyer doing
a particular area of law.
The power in that network
is that's where you have
people who've got your back.
They're the people who can
give you that feedback, maybe
some deep mentorship.
They really know you well,
that team you can instantly
pull together on
a project when you
have a narrow, deep network.
You can already see
the problem with it.
It doesn't create a
lot of opportunities.
So the other network is
a broad, shallow network.
That's typically associated
with the types of relationships
that men have.
The reality is, you need both.
You need those loose ties.
Those loose ties are where
opportunity comes from.
You may not be able
to get deep feedback,
but you can sure spread
a message in a long way.
You sure can find someone
to go, oh god, yeah, right,
I went to college with
someone who's doing that.
Let me reach out to
them and see if they're
interested in talking about
it, or meeting, or whatever.
You need both of those.
And the reality is,
our lives do that.
You think about when
you are in college,
and then those relationships
ebb out this way,
further and further.
But find ways to keep those
people in your periphery.
We're a case study of
that quote in many ways.
If you had just
said, all right, I
had my nice internship
for two months
in New York City in 2012.
Thanks very much, see you later.
ABBY: No way, yeah--
wouldn't be here today.
KELLY HOEY: I wouldn't be
sitting here today, right?
So Abby had been my intern.
And I think that's also-- when
you think about food chain,
we often think of networking
as up the food chain.
And the reality is we
live in a 360 world.
You never know
where opportunities
are going to come from.
Your next boss may be 30 years
older or 30 years younger.
Nurture and take care
of all the relationships
around you, back to being
that decent human being,
because you never know.
You never know who's
going to mentor you.
You never know who
an opportunity's
going to come from.
You never know who
you can help, and that
just creates that vibrancy and
resiliency in a network, which,
in my mind, creates the
vibrancy and resiliency
in your own career.
ABBY: Great, thank you.
I have a lot of more
questions, quite a few
more questions for you
around social media.
You talk a lot about
generosity and how
that plays in the network.
But right now I want to
ask you one more question,
and then I want to open it
up to folks on live stream
and in the room for questions.
So start thinking about them,
or put them on the [INAUDIBLE]
if you feel more comfortable.
But my last question
for you for now
would be, if anyone here
was to go home and change
only one thing about how they
network, what would it be?
KELLY HOEY: Change one thing--
ABBY: It's like "The
Hunger Games" of your book.
KELLY HOEY: Exactly.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KELLY HOEY: You know
what I would do?
[INAUDIBLE] this is the
biggest networking--
because I'm often asked, what is
the biggest networking mistake
people make?
And the biggest networking
mistake people make
is a failure to follow up.
And I don't mean by
that the, hey, Abby--
you know, the email I
could send that said,
hey, Abby, thanks very much
for arranging this chat today.
It's when can I follow
up a month from now?
When is there some time
that you cross my mind
that I could follow up again?
And that failure to follow
up with a piece of advice,
maybe an introduction someone
made, whatever it may be--
and if you do nothing else from
today, go back to your desk,
whatever.
Sit there and look
at your calendar,
and think, right,
where is someone
who has done something for
me that other than the, hey,
thanks a lot, where can I
circle back and let them know
what I've done
with that guidance
or how something turned out?
And that type of follow-up
changes things within networks.
And that changes relationships.
So if you do one thing from
today and change one thing,
master the art of the follow-up.
ABBY: That's a great note
to take some questions on.
Thank you so much.
I want to first open
it up to the room
and see if we have
any live questions.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
on the gender issue.
So you're hinting that
men and women are very
different in networking styles.
And how does that
differentiate the two genders
in terms of career development?
KELLY HOEY: That is a terrific
question in terms of networking
and career development.
Here's the two things that
are running through my mind.
One is, for people
earlier in their career,
I often recommend to them--
I said, look at what it
takes for other people
to be successful in the
area you want to go into.
And part of how
they're successful
is not just the knowledge base.
It's how they interact.
And ask yourself, will
I be as successful
within that interaction?
So I knew I could be
successful as a legal career.
But if I'd chosen to
be a tax attorney,
I would have been
an abject failure.
Their way of networking
is very technical.
It is very research-driven,
and it is very paper-driven,
in terms of writing papers and
things and sending updates.
That is not me.
I was much better
off hanging out,
as I used to refer to them,
with my frat boy Wall Street
clients, because giving
someone a tequila shot
was a heck of a lot easier
than spending endless hours
researching.
But that was my
personality type.
So look ahead and say,
how do they interact?
I also think this
is where there is
power in knowing
why you want to seek
the advice of other people,
because we all operate within,
I want to say, proximity
and communities
that they may have their
patterns of interactions,
and how you can--
you may not want to
completely disrupt it.
But you want to be part
of the conversation.
And this is where you have
to find those opportunities
to seek out people, in
my mind, on their advice
and their guidance of
how they can help you.
So for example, to reach
out to someone and say,
please explain to me why this
happened in your career--
how did you make the move
from HR to engineering?
That intrigues me,
and it doesn't seem
to be a linear career process.
How did that come about?
People want to talk and share
that kind of particular advice.
And so if you find yourself
within an environment
that you don't
think, well, I'm not
going to go out and do
that type of networking,
find other ways to have
conversation that focuses back
on the nature of work.
Does that help?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I have a
[INAUDIBLE] question.
So what advice do you
have for introverts?
KELLY HOEY: [GASPS] This
is my favorite question--
advice for introverts.
We didn't talk about this.
I did mention that the
book is case-study driven.
And I saw people
within my network
that had a particular outcome.
And I said, I need
you to unpack this,
because I have a suspicion
that you have achieved
this goal in a networked way by
building relationships, seeking
the help of others,
building your own expertise,
sharing that within
your network,
and moving towards
whatever your goal is,
whether it's up the
corporate ladder, starting a,
I want to say, a venture
capital fund, climbing
Everest, et cetera.
So I sent out questions to
these people in my book.
And I did not ask
them one question.
I didn't ask them
their personality type.
I didn't ask, how'd you
do on the Myers-Briggs?
How'd you do?
No, didn't ask that
question, and my answers
started coming back.
Most of the people who
were featured in the book
are introverts, and not
a little bit introverted,
really introverted.
I think in this
day and age, when
we are bombarded with
opportunities and information,
online and off,
and choice, I think
people who are more purposeful
and conscientious in how they
network are better networkers.
And my guess is,
those are introverts.
In managing your own discomfort,
in managing your concern
on what your ask may be and
how it may feel or impose
on someone else, I think
you're better positioned
to succeed than extroverts.
I'm going to go really out
on a limb and say that one.
So my advice to introverts
is, any time someone
sends you a networking
tip that says--
maybe it's a link to
an article that's, hey,
10 things introverts can do to
network more like extroverts--
I want you to hit
Delete immediately.
Someone sends you that advice--
I want you to ignore it.
Continue to be conscientious.
Continue to be purposeful.
Continue to understand
why it is you
need to undertake
networking activities.
One of the great case
studies in the book
is a guy by the
name of Joe Styler.
Joe is at GoDaddy.
He networked his way
up from the help desk
to the after-markets department.
So I like to say on my
way from being in New York
and on Wall Street, from being
the receptionist at Goldman
Sachs to lead trader--
he's made that
change in his career,
networking, building
his expertise,
moving his career forward
within his industry very
purposely and very
intentionally within GoDaddy.
And he's like,
hey, there's things
I know I have to do that, if
I look at my personality type,
I know I'm not
comfortable doing them.
But I understand now
why I need to do them,
so I can step into that room.
And he is so purposeful
and so well researched,
any time, I think it's to
manage that discomfort.
But his case study is an
absolutely brilliant one
in terms of someone
who is introverted
moving their career
forward, because if he
had succumbed to introversion
and just been told,
go network, go work
cocktail parties,
he'd probably still
be, you know, hey,
thanks for calling GoDaddy.
This is Joe.
How can I help you-- instead
of in a very fulfilling role
within that company and
within the industry.
AUDIENCE: A technical
question on LinkedIn--
what is your thoughts on the
LinkedIn open networkers?
And how can you use
them as a resource--
struggling with that.
KELLY HOEY: The open networkers,
so people actively connecting
with other people on LinkedIn?
AUDIENCE: Right, so if you
send them a connection,
you don't have any
connection with them.
They will automatically
approve you in their network.
KELLY HOEY: I want to know why.
AUDIENCE: So one of
the benefits they do,
which might not be a
benefit for individuals,
but they're able to connect
groups that are not actually
connected together.
So there's a good society
view that these people play.
But I didn't know how
other, as an individual,
you tactically use
this for those folks.
KELLY HOEY: Yeah,
here's the thing.
As a networking platform, and
to date myself, as a Rolodex,
as a way of keeping
eyeballs on contacts
and thinking about who and
when to contact people,
depending on where I'm going
or industries I'm looking into,
I'm a massive fan of LinkedIn.
And I think also, too,
it has revealed to us--
it's not only your own network.
It is the second- and
third-degree connections
and sort of unveiling
that concept to people
who hadn't heard of it.
I think it's vitally important,
that LinkedIn as a platform.
But there's two
things with LinkedIn--
I think we look at it as
a platform in technology,
and we forget that people
use it differently.
And we use it differently
at different points in time.
So a request to connect without
a personal message, I think,
is meaningless.
Tell me, remind me,
prompt me how and why.
And then when you do
that with other people,
also remember some of us may be
using the network differently.
I know some people who use
LinkedIn very closed off.
If we haven't sat face to face,
if we haven't broken bread,
you're not in my
LinkedIn network.
Other people are,
oh, you know what?
I'm expanding my business.
I've got a new role in sales.
In my own case, I've
got a book to sell.
It's a lot wider, so if someone
was to message me on LinkedIn
and said, hey, loved
hearing your talk
at the University
of Tampa, I was
the one who asked
this question, I'm
likely to connect with them.
It also makes it--
when someone says,
can you make an introduction?
I see you're connected on
LinkedIn to this person.
Can you make the introduction?
That's also where you need to
understand that they may not
have the strongest connection to
people to make an introduction.
So I would be able to say,
oh, yeah, that person?
I know them.
We connected in
Tampa for 10 minutes.
You can reach out
and use my name,
but I don't think I can be that
meaningful in terms of anything
in-depth in a connection.
But we use it
differently, and I think
you've hit on something, in
my mind, which is bigger,
is that when you have digital
tools around networks, when we
focus on the tools themselves
and the technology,
we forget that people
use them differently.
And just remember always,
it's human beings behind that.
And think about the way that--
you using something
is not necessarily
the way somebody else uses it.
And I would say, for anyone in
the room and anyone watching--
so on my website,
jkellyhoey.co--
dot co, it's a dot co,
not a dot com-- there's
a little box that
says Ask Kelly.
Crazy thing-- it comes to me.
[LAUGHTER]
It comes into my Gmail account.
There is no one in between that.
So if you don't get your
question answered today,
just fire me the question.
Say that you were watching
this, and you've got a question,
and I'll answer it.
ABBY: jkelly--
KELLY HOEY: jkellyhoey--
ABBY: Dot co?
KELLY HOEY: Dot co--
it's Ask Kelly,
and Kelly answers.
ABBY: Great, thank you.
AUDIENCE: All right.
To build on top of
the previous question,
what other tools do you use
to keep track of your network?
Oftentimes, I realize that
I don't remember people
very well.
And a lot of engineers,
I think, have
this problem of short memory.
And oftentimes, I
would find myself--
hey, there was this problem.
And I didn't think of contacting
this person, and only two
weeks later, to realize he would
have solved this issue very
quickly.
KELLY HOEY: Yeah, yeah, I
wish I had the magic solution
for remembering these things.
I am very, I want to say,
geography-based in my thinking,
in terms of when I
start problem solving.
I think of networking as-- it's
the way you've just described
it, like problem solving.
Who can help me
with this problem?
I'm often very geography-
or company-based when
I think of it.
Sometimes I'm like, OK,
where did I meet them?
Where did I meet them?
And I have to kind of
go down this waterfall.
I would say for
anyone, figure out
how you start to problem-solve
in these situations.
Who have I met?
And then you'll
probably figure out
what is the best way for you
to organize your contacts.
Are you someone who
would go to LinkedIn?
Is a spreadsheet
the answer for you?
Is there some other--
is it groups on Google+?
Figure it out.
Start to think about
how you problem-solve
and need the help
of other people.
And figure out from
there, what are
the ways I can clump
people in different things
to be able to say,
you know what?
I just met this person.
We talked about this stuff.
He or she may be a good person
to ask this type of question
in the future.
Figure a way to tag
them or do something.
But part of it, I
think, maybe all
of this with the
book and networking
is a whole lot of
self-awareness,
a whole lot of
self-awareness about
how you operate
within this world,
but how you reach
out to other people
and how you can do that in a
way that is more effective,
but I wish I had the
ultimate dashboard.
Maybe that's the
next thing I create.
ABBY: 2018.
KELLY HOEY: There we go.
Because I didn't have
enough projects to do.
I'll come up with a dashboard.
Because it is something--
people are always like,
where is the Rolodex,
the CRM system?
I am not a spreadsheet person.
But if that's what works for
you, put it in a spreadsheet.
ABBY: It's so great
to have you here.
And I hesitate to
say if you want
to leave us with any
departing wisdom, because I
think that's what the last
45 minutes was all about.
[LAUGHTER]
But any closing thoughts or
final remarks before we wrap?
KELLY HOEY: I just
want to say go forth
and be better human beings.
That's all that we
all can ask for.
And I think if we understand
that we're networking
with other people,
that their lives are
complicated and messy, if we
can stop and observe and listen
a little bit more
before we interact,
we will improve
our interactions.
ABBY: Thank you, that's great.
Kelly, it's been awesome
to have you here.
KELLY HOEY: Thank
you, thank you.
ABBY: We really
appreciate it, thank you.
KELLY HOEY: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ABBY: Thanks, everybody.